Australia es uno de los países más ricos
del mundo.
Es más, hasta antes de la pandemia podían
presumir de no haber sufrido ninguna crisis
económica.
Sin embargo...
¿Sabríais nombrarme alguna empresa australiana?
Pensadlo bien, hablamos del país del futuro.
Basta echar un vistazo a ciudades como Melbourne
o Sidney para imaginarse cómo será el mundo
en 2050.
Da igual el ranking que miremos, Australia
siempre está en los mejores puestos.
Los australianos disfrutan del segundo salario
mínimo más alto del planeta con casi 2.000
euros mensuales.
Además son una de las economías más libres
del mundo, donde es más fácil hacer negocios
pero, a la vez, con un estado del bienestar
envidiable.
Cuando el mundo entero sufría la gran crisis
financiera, los australianos estaban creciendo
a un 2%.
Incluso ahora, con la crisis del coronavirus,
Australia puede presumir de estar en una situación
mucho mejor que cualquier otro país.
En una palabra: Australia es un país rico.
Muy rico.
Sin embargo, vuelvo a la misma pregunta ¿Conocéis
alguna empresa australiana?
Posiblemente no muchas.
Os puede sonar la aerolínea Qantas.
También es australiana la marca de ropa Rip
Curl.
Y si hay algún compañero YouTuber por aquí,
tal vez conozcáis otra más: RODE Microphones.
Por ejemplo, el micrófono del que os estoy
hablando es de esta marca.
Y sí, estos micrófonos son australianos.
En cualquier caso, hablamos de empresas relativamente
pequeñas ¿Dónde están el Google o el BMW
australiano?
Por eso la pregunta de hoy es ¿De dónde
viene la riqueza tan impresionante de Australia?
¿Qué venden al mundo para ser tan ricos?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes… ya que estamos hablando de Australia,
el país del surf por antonomasia… vamos
a hablar ahora de surfear en Internet ¿Por
qué?
Porque Internet tiene cada vez más restricciones
geográficas.
Así que, si queréis navegar por Internet
libremente, incluso por páginas web australianas,
tendráis que usar una VPN ¿Y cuál es la
VPN favorita de VisualPolitik?
¡Pues claro que sí!
Surfshark VPN.
Surfshark es una VPN fantástica y super segura.
Por ejemplo ¿No os ha pasado alguna vez que
entráis en una web y os salen un montón
de ventanitas de publicidad?
Pues eso se llama PHISHING, y por ahí se
cuelan montones de cookies y de virus que
se meten en el móvil o el ordenador.
Pues, como ya sabéis todos, SurfShark tiene
una herramienta que se llama CleanWeb que
bloquea todos estos pop ups y todos estos
enlaces que tienen más peligro que un saco
de bombas ¡Pero no sólo eso!
Con una única cuenta de Surfshark podéis
registrar todos los dispositivos que queráis:
el móvil, la tablet, el portátil… ¡No
hay ningún límite de dispositivos!
Y como siempre, tenemos una oferta muy especial
para todos vosotros que seguís VisualPolitik.
Básicamente, si usáis el código “POLITIK”,
tendréis un 83% de descuento… más 3 meses
extra totalmente gratis.
Es más, podéis probar Surfshark durante
los primeros 30 días sin ningún compromiso.
En la descripción os dejo los enlaces.
TIERRA DE OPORTUNIDADES
En el año 1788, Australia no era nada más
que una colonia penal británica.
Es decir, era el lugar donde Reino Unido mandaba
a sus presos.
Tal cual como lo oís.
Para que la Australia moderna se convirtiera
en uno de los países más ricos del mundo
fue fundamental el olfato para los negocios
de una serie de buscavidas.
El primero de nuestros protagonistas es John
Macarthur, un militar británico que hizo
llegar a Australia ovejas merinas españolas
con las que fundó un imperio de la lana.
Así empezó todo en Australia, algo que quedó
inmortalizado con la siguiente frase.
Australia cabalgó hacia la prosperidad a
lomos de las ovejas
Desde entonces, Australia sigue siendo el
principal productor de lana del mundo.
Y el señor Macarthur ha quedado inmortalizado
en los billetes de este país.
Lo que está claro es que en Australia había
sitio más que suficiente para tener grandes
rebaños de ovejas.
Pero es que además la historia ha sido la
gran aliada de la lana australiana.
Gran Bretaña compró toda la producción
australiana durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Y durante la guerra de Corea sus precios se
dispararon por la demanda estadounidense de
lana para vestir a sus tropas.
Lo que pasa es que los tiempos cambian, y
los compradores, también:
El precio de la lana en Australia sube a medida
que repunta la demanda de China
Pero esperad un momento amigos, porque no
solo de lana vive Australia.
A mediados del siglo XIX estalló en Australia
una fiebre del oro que nada tiene que envidiar
a las vividas en otros países.
Desde entonces Australia sigue siendo el principal
productor de oro del mundo ¡Pero no sólo
hablamos de oro!
En realidad Australia tiene TODO: hierro,
carbón, aluminio, cobre, uranio... y por
supuesto, gas natural y petróleo.
Vamos, que es más fácil decir lo que no
tiene.
Si a esto la sumamos que están al lado de
Asia, ya tenemos toda la historia ¿Quién
pone los recursos naturales para todo ese
crecimiento de China y del Sudeste asiático?
¡Exacto!
Australia.
Gracias a eso, Australia es tan rica.
Ale, pues fin del vídeo ¿no?
¡Que no me voy hombre!
¿Cómo íbamos a daros una respuesta tan
simple?
¡Ya sé lo que estaréis pensando!
Si de verdad sois seguidores de VisualPolitik,
de los que no se pierde ningún vídeo porque
ha dado a la campanita al suscribirse, ya
sabéis que tener recursos naturales no significa
nada.
Si tener recursos naturales fuera sinónimo
de ser rico, Argentina sería Suiza y Suiza
sería Argentina.
Es más, en realidad se podría hablar de
la “maldición” de los recursos naturales.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Cómo ha evitado
Australia esa maldición de los recursos naturales?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
VIEJAS RIQUEZAS, NUEVAS TÉCNICAS
Tener recursos naturales no es siempre una
buena noticia.
De lo contrario, Africa sería el continente
más rico del mundo.
Cuando un país descubre recursos naturales
suele ocurrir una de estas dos cosas: a) Escenario
del Congo: Tienen enormes reservas de tantalio
y se forman guerrillas que se matan entre
ellas para explotarlo. b) Escenario de Venezuela:
tienen petróleo, basan toda su economía
en explotarlo y se arruinan cuando el precio
de mercado del barril cae, el país se hunde
en la miseria.
Australia eligió otro camino.
Los australianos siempre han tenido recursos
naturales.
Pero el auténtico boom de la minería australiana
llegó hace 40 años.
En ese momento, Australia ya tenía instituciones
democráticas, transparentes y libres.
A fin de cuentas, habían copiado el modelo
de Reino Unido ¿Y por qué es tan importante
que todo esto fuera así?
Pues porque en Australia se formó el caldo
de cultivo perfecto para que allí hoy día
vivan en el futuro.
BHP planea un gran despliegue de automatización
en Australia
Robots de minería: Rio Tinto duplica la perforación
autónoma
En otras palabras: el sector minero de Australia
no se parece en nada al clásico minero con
su pico y su pala.
Al contrario: al tener unas instituciones
que permiten la creación de empresas y la
competencia, las mineras australianas han
tenido que apostar por la innovación.
Hoy en día, la minería es uno de los sectores
más tecnológicos que existen.
Empresas como BHP o Río Tinto son como el
Apple de los recursos naturales.
Así que Australia no sólo exporta recursos
naturales.
También exporta tecnología.
Así se explica que muchas empresas australianas
exploten los recursos de otros países.
Lundin vende la mina de oro más grande de
Ecuador a una minera australiana
Gracias a todo esto que os estamos contando
es evidente que a Australia le ha ido muy
bien.
Precisamente hace más de 50 años nos avanzó
como sería el país el que, por entonces,
era su primer ministro.
Atentos:
Esta Australia nuestra es un vasto continente
insular habitado en gran parte por personas
de origen británico o europeo y con un legado
de libertad nacional, libertad personal y
las instituciones de una democracia parlamentaria
británica.
Pero geográficamente somos parte de Asia,
y cada vez hemos tomado más conciencia de
nuestra participación en los asuntos de Asia.
–Harold Holt, Primer Ministro Australiano,
1966 - 1967.
Y sí, estar cerca de Asia ha sido crucial
para la economía de Australia: el hierro
ha superado a la lana como el principal producto
de exportación de Australia gracias a la
demanda de las acerías chinas.
Así que igual que los países árabes se
hicieron de oro con el boom del precio del
petróleo, Australia se ha beneficiado del
crecimiento económico de Asia en las últimas
décadas.
Australia apenas consume un 15% de su producción
de carbón.
Y no produce poco carbón precisamente: un
8% del que se produce en todo el planeta,
lo que le convierte en el cuarto mayor productor
después de China, Indonesia y Estados Unidos.
Así que el resto lo vende, lo que hace que
Australia sea el mayor exportador mundial
con una cuota de mercado del 27%.
Solamente entre Japón y China compran más
de la mitad del carbón que exporta Australia.
Pero esperad un momento, porque si estos datos
del carbón son muy buenos para Australia
y no tanto para el planeta, tenéis que ver
lo que ha pasado con el boom del gas natural
licuado.
Ya os hemos hablado unas cuantas veces en
VisualPolitik sobre el GNL.
El gas natural se puede transportar de dos
formas: en gasoducto (ya sabéis, kilómetros
y kilómetros de tubos para llevar el gas
natural); o como GNL, es decir, enfrías el
gas hasta pasarlo a estado líquido, lo metes
en buques metaneros y lo envías a la planta
regasificadora de destino.
Pues bien, el despertar económico de China
y el apagón nuclear de Japón han disparado
la demanda de gas en Asia ¿Y quién estaba
cerca para aprovecharse de ello?
Efectivamente, Australia y sus reservas de
gas.
No es que sean muy grandes, apenas el 1% de
las que actualmente se estima que hay en el
planeta.
Para que os hagáis una idea, Qatar tiene
10 veces más gas.
SIn embargo, Australia es el segundo exportador
de gas del mundo.
Aún así son suficientes para que la producción
gasista de Australia se haya triplicado en
los últimos 10 años, pasando de ser el decimoctavo
país que más gas produce del mundo a ser
el séptimo productor mundial.
Así que Australia está a un paso de entrar
en la Champions League de los productores
de gas.
Y como apenas consume un tercio del gas que
produce, ¿qué creéis que hace con los otros
2 tercios?
Pues efectivamente, a enfriar y al barquito
metanero navegando hacia Asia.
Como estáis viendo, Australia tiene muchos
motivos para el optimismo.
Y diréis...
¡Pero vamos a ver, Fonseca!
Lo que estás describiendo es una economía
muy dependiente de los recursos naturales.
En VisualPolitik siempre nos contáis que
eso es un problema ¿De verdad Australia es
la excepción?
Pues no, no lo es.
Ahora vamos a ver la cara más oscura de la
economía australiana.
EL MAL HOLANDÉS
Si descubrir recursos naturales suele provocar
que se multipliquen los gobernantes corruptos,
con Australia podemos aprender que, aún teniendo
buenos gobernantes, tarde o temprano aparecen
los problemas.
Fundamentalmente porque si para hacer fortuna
te vale con coger una pala y excavar, porque
en Australia siempre encuentras algo, pues
es evidente que no hay incentivos para desarrollar
otras industrias diferentes a la minería.
Pero esperad un momento amigos, porque hay
algo peor.
Hay problemas que son como una infección
que se extiende por toda la economía.
Hablamos del llamado mal holandés.
¿En qué consiste?
Pues básicamente en que te pase lo mismo
que le pasó a Países Bajos cuando descubrió
campos de gas en los años 70.
Os pongo un ejemplo: de repente un país descubre
cantidades ingentes de un recurso.
Pongamos que es el hierro australiano; y tienes
tanto hierro que le das salida exportándolo,
vendiéndoselo a empresas de otros países.
Pero claro, ¿Cuál es la moneda del comercio
internacional?
El dólar estadounidense.
En otras palabras, las mineras australianas
ingresan millones y millones de dólares estadounidenses
pero tienen que pagar sus impuestos en Australia
con dólares... australianos.
¿Qué hacen?
Pues comprar moneda local.
Es decir, cambiar sus dólares estadounidenses
por australianos ¿Y qué significa todo esto?
Pues que, de repente, la demanda del dólar
australiano se dispara ¿Y qué pasa cuando
la demanda de una divisa se dispara?
Pues que crece su precio.
Es decir, que en lugar de devaluarse, la moneda
se revalúa.
Fijaos en este gráfico.
Como veis en el gráfico, desde el año 2000
hasta el 2011, el dólar australiano ha duplicado
su valor respecto al estadounidense.
Tras el 2011, esta valoración se ha moderado.
Durante la crisis del coronavirus, el dolar
australiano ha caído un poco ¿Todo esto
qué significa?
Que por fin los australianos están empezando
a experimentar un poco de inflación.
Y ya sé lo que os estaréis preguntando ¿Desde
cuando es malo que tu divisa no se devalúe?
Teoricamente, el mejor escenario para un país
sería el de tener una divisa fuerte.
Así, los ciudadanos no sufren inflación
y pueden hacer inversiones en el largo plazo.
En otras palabras: al tener una moneda tan
cara, los australianos tienen más poder adquisitivo
que los de casi cualquier otro país.
Un australiano puede viajar por el mundo y
todo le parecerá barato.
Puede permitirse comprar cualquier cosa del
extranjero con más facilidad que un estadounidense
o un europeo ¿Verdad?
Pues sí, tenéis razón.
Pero tener una moneda que se revalúa constantemente
también tiene problemas ¿Qué problemas?
Pues atentos.
Cierre de Holden: la historia australiana
de fabricación de automóviles llega a su
fin
Primero cerró Ford, luego Toyota y finalmente
lo hizo Holden.
Y claro, Ford y Toyota seguro que sabéis
que son firmas de Estados Unidos y Japón.
Pero es que Holden, aunque formaba parte de
General Motors, es la marca por excelencia
del coche australiano.
Bueno, más bien era, porque en febrero de
2020 cerró definitivamente.
¿Y qué es lo relevante del cierre de las
fábricas de coches en Australia?
Pues que en el fondo es todo un símbolo de
las penurias por las que está pasando la
industria manufacturera australiana.
El mal holandés le ha hecho perder competitividad
por todos lados: al tener sueldos tan altos,
es muy difícil competir con el extranjero.
Y diréis ¡Venga ya, Fonseca!
Si eso fuera cierto, Suiza no tendría empresas.
Pues sí, tenéis razón... el problema es
que Suiza no tiene recursos mineros.
Y aquí es donde entra el mal holandés.
Los sueldos altos hacen que sólo sea rentable
crear industrias de altísimo valor añadido.
Pero la gente que podría crear esas industrias
está demasiado ocupada trabajando en el ultra
rentable mundo de la minería ¿Conclusión?
En pocos años, toda tu economía depende
de tus recursos naturales.
En otras palabras, te acabas de convertir
en Arabia Saudita.
Para que os hagáis una idea, más de la mitad
de las exportaciones de Australia son recursos
naturales.
De hecho, hay un ranking en el que Australia
está a la altura de otros países tan poco
ejemplares como Burkina Faso o Uganda ¿A
qué ranking me estoy refiriendo?
Al ranking de complejidad económica.
Este ranking mide, por un lado, el nivel de
diversificación de un país y la diferenciación
de sus productos.
Por ejemplo, Japón es el país más complejo
en este índice ¿Por qué?
Porque Japón exporta un montón de productos
tecnológicos únicos.
Una televisión SONY es una televisión SONY,
distinta de otras televisiones.
Sin embargo, una tonelada de hierro es igual
en todas partes.
Pues bien, en este terreno Australia sale
muy mal parada.
Y diréis ¿Entonces... esto significa que
los australianos están al borde de ser una
nueva Venezuela o una Arabia Saudita?
¡Para nada!
De entrada, Australia cuenta con instituciones
sólidas como para, una vez la minería dejara
de ser rentable, pudieran surgir otras industrias.
De hecho, esto es exactamente lo que ocurrió
en Países Bajos.
Países Bajos es el país que puso el nombre
al “mal holandés”.
Sin embargo, nadie puede decir que hoy en
día sean una economía poco diversa o que
estén en declive ¡Pero no sólo eso!
A diferencia de otros países, Australia cuenta
con unos políticos que saben mirar a corto
plazo.
Y eso explica campañas como esta.
Esta campaña en Bloomberg, que como sabéis
es uno de los medios de comunicación más
grandes del campo de las finanzas, la promueve
el Estado de Victoria, con capital en Melbourne.
En general, los políticos aussies se están
moviendo para diversificar la economía.
Para ello están intentando atraer inversiones
extranjeras que contribuyan a desarrollar
sectores más innovadores.
El Gobierno de Victoria trae empresas tecnológicas
para invertir en el estado
Los resultados de este tipo de campañas se
recogerán en el medio plazo y aún no se
pueden evaluar.
Lo que sí sabemos es que una saga de jóvenes
compañías australianas ya han empezado a
abrirse camino en el mundo de la economía
digital desde el país de los canguros.
Hablamos de plataformas para trabajadores
freelance como Freelancer o 99designs, empresas
fintech como Judo Bank o software avanzado
como Canva.
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
¿Creéis que estos esfuerzos para superar
el mal holandés serán suficientes?
¿Consideráis que Australia podría ser el
lugar ideal si tuvierais que emprender un
nuevo negocio?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.